ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BAKER
FORGES BRADFORD CABALLERO
ATTENDEE DALLY DODD DURAZO
EGGMAN GONZALEZ GROSS HERTZBERG
HUESO HER TADO JONES PAIRED
LEYVA MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN.
NEWMAN NIELSEN A CHIRLA VOTE.
PAN PORTANTINO PROF RUBIO
SKINNER STERN AMBERG WHY CASKEY
WIENER WILK. MEMBERS OF A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR LEYVA AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR. FURTADO GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS. MERCIFUL AND HEALING
GOD TODAY WE BEGIN BLACK
HISTORY MONTH WHERE WE
CELEBRATE THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
OF BLACK PEOPLE AS THEY HAVE
STRUGGLED TO BE KNOWLEDGE AND
RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO SOCIETY. WE
SHARE IN THE LONGINGS OF
LANGSTON HUGHES'S POEM I DREAM
A WORLD. AND WE COMMIT TO
DISMANTLING SYSTEMS OF RACISM
THAT KEEPS ALL OF US UNFREE. I
DREAM A WORLD WHERE MAN NO ONE.
NONE OTHER WILL SCORN. FOR
LEVEL BLESSED SEARS MPS IT'S
PAST ADORN. A DREAMY WORLD WERE
ALL WILL KNOW SWEET FREEDOM'S
WAY WHERE GREED NO LONGER SAPS
THE SOUL NOR AVARICE BLADES ARE
DAY. A WORLD I DREAM WHERE
BLACK OR WHITE WERE EVER RACE
YOU BE WILL SHARE THE BOUNTIES
OF THE EARTH AND EVERYONE IS
FREE. WHERE WRETCHEDNESS WILL
HANG ITS HEAD ENJOY LIKE A
PEARL ATTENDS THE NEED OF HUMAN
KIND. OF SUCH I DREAM MY WORLD
MAYBE WORK FOR SUCH A DREAM
AMEN. COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. AND TO THE REPUBLIC
FOR WHICH IT STANDS ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE SENATOR
BATES GLACIER AND LIMóN
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. GOOD
AFTERNOON TO EVERYBODY MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE SENATE JOURNALS FOR THE
WEEK OF JANUARY TWENTY FIFTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE KIRK. INTRODUCTION AND
FIRST READING OF BILLS. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL. TWO EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY ONE
TO EIGHTY TWO TO EIGHTY THREE
TO EIGHTY FOUR TO EIGHTY FIVE
TO EIGHTY SIX TO EIGHTY SEVEN
AND SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR
GONZALEZ. MADAM PRESIDENT THE
SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
WILL MEET UPON ADJOURNMENT WE
JUST NEED ABOUT THIRTY MINUTES-
WILL MEET HERE IN SENATE
CHAMBERS. VERY GOOD OTHER
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT SENATOR
LARRY YES. HOME JOINT
LEGISLATIVE WHATEVER WILL MEET
IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS UPON
ADJOURNMENT VERY BRIEF AGENDA
VERY GOOD IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR ATKINS THE
DESK IS CLEAR. START. SENATE
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH OUR
NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED
FOR THURSDAY FEBRUARY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT NINE AM
SHARP THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT
NINE AM. THANK YOU SENATORS.